هذا ما بقي من السواتر الترابيه لما يسمى
هنا بسد التلول الترابي بعد فيضان نهر
العاصي فخوفا من الاثار المحتمله للزلزال
فتحت السلطات التابعه للنظام السوري مياه
سد الرستن على نفس النهر ما اسفر عن زياده
مستوى المياه فيه في ادلب
غادر السكان بيوتهم خوفا من ان تحاصرهم
المياه اخرج ابو احمد افراد عائلته وبقي
في بيته على امل ان ينتهي الامر سريعا
مخلصنا الزلزال
شردنا
والله عيالي كانوا بالمخيم ساكنين اجا خبر
العاصي
وين صاروا ما بعرف هون
تتشابهوا صور النزوح وتختلف اسبابه فالخوف
من الغرق اجبر العائلات على مغادره القريه
الى مناطق امنه لا تصلها المياه يخشى
السكان هنا من زياده كميه المياه المتدفقه
وسط غياب اي حلول ما يعني زياده عدد
النازحين اضافه الى الذين غادروا المنطقه
بسبب تصدع بيوتهم بعد الزلزال تجمع المياه
يشكل خطرا كبيرا على البيوت التي تصدعت
بسبب الزلزال وقد دمر بشكل كامل اكثر من
عشرين بيتا في القريه وانتشلت فرق الدفاع
المدني اكثر من 30 شخصا قضوا تحت انقاض
منازلهم وما بقي في القريه يخشى السكان ان
تدمره المياه
تستمر عمليات الانقاذ في المدن والبلدات
القريبه من الحدود التركيه
وتتضاءل الاعمال بالعثور على ناجين تحت
جبال الركام التي خلفها الزلزال صهيب
الخلف الجزيره ادلب